Ognuno di noi ha una storia da
raccontare se solo ci fosse qualcuno
disposto ad ascoltarla relazioni sono
fondamentali per l'uomo e rappresentano
la chiave per il futuro ora quando noi
pensiamo alle relazioni cosa vi viene in
mente io ho pensato a questa immagine
cioè
possiamo dire che le reazioni
rappresentano un bene si parla infatti
di beni relazionali che caratteristiche
hanno questi beni la natura non
strumentale infatti in essi noi
incontriamo gratuita e non interessi
nelle relazioni Io miglioro la mia
autostima mi conosco
comprendo ciò che mi circonda mi sento
amato
relazioni sono anche la chiave della
felicità Infatti a volte quando
colleghiamo la felicità La leghiamo a
dei concetti come il denaro degli eventi
come il successo ma in realtà
relazioni sono la chiave della felicità
le relazioni sane reali positive
Non a caso gli effetti di una
separazione o di un litigio sono
deleteri e lasciano dei traumi nei figli
e non solo perché abbiamo bisogno di
relazioni vere
possiamo sentirci soli anche in mezzo
alla folla o in una relazione stabile
quindi non è tanto il numero delle
relazioni che conta quanto la qualità
che ci aiuta
relazioni quindi ci proteggono
fisicamente e psicologicamente
nell'essere umano
è nata la tendenza nella ricerca di una
figura di accudimento il caregiver che
deve comprendere i bisogni del bambino e
attuare così nel tempo un adeguata
capacità responsiva
le prime interazioni che il bambino ha
con il mondo esterno sono
fondamentali per il suo percorso di
crescita Così come per il suo sviluppo
cognitivo affettivo e sociale
viceversa possiamo dire che i primi
traumi Soprattutto quelli della prima
infanzia possono
portare a delle complicanze cliniche
psicologiche e psichiatriche piuttosto
pericolose ma esse possono essere
ammortizzate da un ambiente
supportivo caloroso ed accogliente
Inoltre non dobbiamo dimenticare che
l'interazione con l'ambiente è reciproca
io influenzo ciò che mi circonda e
viceversa
un bambino molto
frenetico genererà nei genitori
attenzione sollecitudine Maggiore
preoccupazione
ci sono anche dei momenti in cui le
reazioni sono ancor più fondamentali che
sono i momenti
di dolore i momenti di difficoltà in cui
incontriamo Le patologie ed è una prassi
ormai consolidata ad esempio nella
terapia oncologica di affiancare il
paziente a una rete di supporto che
permette di affrontare la malattia in
maniera più positiva
per dare più possibilità di superamento
Perché da solo non ce la faccio ma
insieme si può in compagnia mi sento più
sicuro
sono rassicurato sono più tranquillo
relazioni sono fondamentali anche nei
traumi o nel lutto Il contenimento
l'elaborazione e la trasformazione
sono fondamentali in uno scambio sociale
un ingaggio relazionale perché
permettono l'elaborazione più rapida se
ci pensiamo Non a caso diciamo diamo le
condoglianze c'è un momento di
condivisione sociale
in cui possiamo esprimere la nostra
disperazione e siamo
accolti da coloro che ci circondano e ci
supportano e questo permette
un'elaborazione maggiore in mancanza di
Essa invece
il dolore permane ed è più duraturo
Quindi abbiamo compreso che le relazioni
sono fondamentali per l'uomo così come
l'isolamento e dannoso e c'è
un'esperienza che ognuno di noi ha
vissuto poco tempo fa
il lockdown durante la pandemia in cui
ciascuno di noi ha sentito la necessità
del contatto il bisogno degli abbracci
abbiamo sperimentato la difficoltà
dell'isolamento e così abbiamo cercato
delle soluzioni come ad esempio la
comunicazione digitale Non a caso in
quel periodo il tempo medio utilizzato
nelle piattaforme e aumentato a
dismisura
ma nonostante questo rimedio apparente
le conseguenze della pandemia come
sappiamo sono ancora sotto gli occhi di
tutti
stati ansiosi crisi depressive aumento
delle separazioni dei divorzi
l'uomo quindi comprende che la relazione
gli fa bene
e l'isolamento è un male Tant'è che ha
paura del silenzio se ci pensate nel
nostro mondo occidentale
siamo invasi
di copertura di silenzio per esempio
pensiamo nei centri commerciali o nelle
sale d'attesa c'è quella musica di
sottofondo che ci intrattiene O magari
anche noi stessi quando siamo sul tram
che mettiamo le cuffiette o magari
tornando a casa
accendiamo la televisione ora radio Non
tanto per ascoltare l'informazione
che il mezzo ci può fornire quanto per
farci compagnia
perché l'uomo
ha paura del silenzio dentro di sé e
intorno a sé e allora si riempie di
suoni e oggetti
e non trova a volte dei momenti per
leggere
diciamo sempre meno ascoltare
parlare con il prossimo
anche con l'amico che ho a fianco magari
a pranzo semplicemente con la persona
che sta aspettando insieme con me la
metro
l'uomo ha paura del silenzio
al contempo con un piccolo click tramite
il PC o lo smartphone
entriamo in un mondo di connessioni
illimitate
Ma si tratta di connessioni di relazioni
virtuali
delle azioni hanno bisogno del contatto
cioè de si fanno con il tatto con la
nostra corporeità emotività con me
stesso
Ecco quindi che se abbiamo capito che le
relazioni sono fondamentali l'isolamento
è dannoso Perché l'uomo non scegliere le
azioni
perché il futuro
non è visto come una speranza
hai visto
in un'ottica di paura
una problematica e quindi scelgo le
soluzioni più immediate più facili che
non sempre sono quelle giuste
perché siamo immersi in una visione
autoconsumistica Per cui provvedo da
solo ce la faccio
se ci pensiamo
il progetto della modernità è consentito
nel ridurre se non proprio eliminare a
volte il concetto di vulnerabilità di
fragilità morte problematiche sociali
per cui ho paura di tuffarmi nelle
relazioni perché ho paura che l'altro mi
tradisca mi abbandoni
non investo emotivamente
questo si vede ancor di più nelle
relazioni a lungo termine nei per sempre
quindi occorre che il futuro
se ha visto in un'ottica di speranza e
si apra al concetto di vulnerabilità
perché la fragilità fa parte dell'uomo
fa parte di noi stessi e ad essa si
connette il concetto di cura
Mi prendo
cura di ciò che mi circonda cioè il
mantenere custodire a crescere tutto ciò
che mi circonda perché mi sta a cuore
quindi occorre passare da questa visione
di autonomia consumistica ad una
interdipendenza
umana tutti noi abbiamo bisogno gli uni
degli altri nella nostra individualità
Allora vorrei concludere questo mio
intervento con una frase
nella vita
non c'è tempo per contese litigi rancori
c'è solo il tempo per amare Grazie
[Applauso]